Hi, welcome back.
We're approaching the end of this class
and some of you might have been
surprised that there is one investment
class that I've completely not talked
about during the course of the class.
It's an investment that's recent in
origin, but it's on everybody's minds
even if it's not in their portfolios.
I'm SP speaking specifically about
Bitcoin and how it might or might not
fit in your portfolio. To understand
Bitcoin though, you need to go back in
time to its creation.
It's the legend is out there of a of a
creator is, you know, with a with a
pseudonym, I think, Satoshi Nakamoto.
But the paper that con that came up with
the Bitcoin idea was written in November
of 2008. At least it was made public.
And for those of you who remember what
November of 2008 looked like, it was two
months in into one of the worst
financial crises we've had in the last
century. And a crisis that shook our
faith. Shook our faith in government,
shook our faith in banks, shook our
faith in central banks and institutions
in general. You're saying, "So what?"
Bitcoin was born in a moment of
distrust. And the design of Bitcoin
reflects it. In fact, when you look at
Bitcoin, it's built on the presumption
that you can trust no one. You can't
trust central banks. You can't trust
governments. And the way this shows up
is in the way in which Bitcoin
transactions get verified.
The notion of a blockchain is
revolutionary, but it's really
crowdchecking transactions. That's what
a blockchain does. If you think about
how paper currency works, you walk into
a store and you pay with a $20 bill. Why
does the shopkeeper take it? Because
it's an element of trust. the $20 bill
you assume is not counterfeit and
essentially that'll buy it. In fact,
even to show you that paper currency can
differ depending on the currency you're
using. Um, if I used a $100 bill, many
stores won't take it because they're
worried about it could could might be a
counterfeit bill. The truth is much of
traditional transaction is built on
trust. Trusting bank a banker, trusting
a central bank, trusting paper
currencies, Bitcoin because there is no
trust. The way in which you check a
transaction is you crowd check the
transaction. People getting on their
computers checking for a nine-digit
number to make sure your transaction
works through. I mean, I've long
described Bitcoin as a currency designed
by the paranoid for the paranoid. And
I've taken some heat for it, but I will
stick with that because there's nothing
wrong again with being paranoid if that
paranoia is based on something out there
that could be real. So with that lead
in, let's think about what makes Bitcoin
so newsworthy. It's no secret the
biggest reason Bitcoin is in the news is
what's happened to its price. If you
look at Bitcoin's prices over the last
decade, they've gone from close to
nothing to $100,000.
Put simply, if you'd put your money in
Bitcoin 10 years ago, you'd have
outstripped anybody in the stock market,
the bond market, gold, whatever other
investment class. and Bitcoin is some
very high-profile supporters, especially
in in in Silicon Valley who view it as
the next best thing. So, let's step back
and think about, hey, how should I think
about Bitcoin? To assess Bitcoin, you
have to first start off by deciding what
it is. If you think what what do you
mean what is it? I mean, if you remember
a few sessions ago, I broke down
investments into assets, commodities,
currencies, and collectibles. And I said
assets can be valued because they have
cash flows. Examples of assets, stocks
and bonds and businesses. Commodities
can be valued at a macro level based on
you know demand and supply at the macro
level. Iron or you know oil price oil
those are commodities.
Both assets and commodities can also be
priced. So you can price and value those
two. Currencies and collectibles can
only be priced. The question is where
does Bitcoin fall in this mix? Is
Bitcoin an asset? I don't see how it can
be because there are no cash flows. You
buy Bitcoin and you hold it, you get no
cash flows. You could design something
with Bitcoin that pays cash flows. But
you can design something with dollars
that generates cash flows. A bond is
designed might have be dollar based, but
it's not the dollar itself that is the
asset. It's a bond that you create. You
could create a contractual obligation
around Bitcoin that is an asset. But
Bitcoin itself is not an asset.
Is it a commodity? I don't think so.
There might be other cryptos that can be
used as raw material to do something.
Bitcoin, that's a stretch. I don't think
it fits a commodity. So, it's either a
currency or a collectible. And even
within its advocates, people are not
sure what to push for. Should I push for
a currency? Should I push for a
collectible? But the question about is
Bitcoin worth 100,000, 80,000, 60,000 is
really a question about is it a good
currency? Is it a good collectible? So,
let's try to address that question. The
reality check with Bitcoin is you cannot
value it because it's not an asset. If
it's a currency, it should be judged on
whether it's a good currency. So, let's
pause right there and ask what makes for
a good currency. Think about why we hold
currency. It's as a medium of exchange.
You want to pay for things and is a
store of value. Good currency is a good
medium of exchange. You should be able
to convert it to, you know, whatever you
need to buy from a from lunch if that's
what you're or a house if you're buying
it. It's a medium of exchange and it
should hold its value.
So, you can already see why even within
paper currencies is a continuum. The
Swiss Frank is a great currency. Why?
Not only is it a medium of exchange in
Switzerland, but you could travel
anywhere in the world and you have no
trouble converting Swiss Franks into the
local currency and spending it. And it's
a great store of value. I tell the story
of putting a 100 Swiss Franks into my
pocket on one of my trips, forgetting
about it, ending up two years later in
Zurich airport, pulling the 100 franks
out, and being able to buy almost
exactly what I would have bought two
years ago. Why? Because there's almost
no inflation. The Swiss Frank, great
currency. Swiss Frank is a much better
currency than the Indian rupee. I mean,
don't take me wrong. I mean, I I hold
rupees in my pocket. It's a good medium
of exchange in India
but once you leave India it becomes
trickier. There are much of the world
you can't convert take your rupees into
a bank convert into local currency. So
it's a decent medium of exchange and
it's a decent store of value. What sense
if you have 6 8% inflation you put a,000
rupees in your pocket and you forget
about it for 2 years you'll be able to
buy less when it comes out. And
Venezuelan Boulevard don't even get me
started. It's a fiat currency but it's a
terrible currency.
Even within Venezuela, people don't want
to accept it because it loses value
while you hold it and it definitely
doesn't hold value. So this notion of
fiat versus crypto is a false one. It's
really a question of, you know, is it a
good currency? And within fiat
currencies, you can have great
currencies, good currencies, average
currencies, bad currencies. The question
you got to ask is where in that
continuum would we put Bitcoin? We'll
hold off on that question for a moment.
If it's a collectible, the question are
asking is it a good collectible? If you
remember our discussion of gold, think
of what made for a collectible. It was
scarce. It was durable. It was
desirable. It's been desirable for a
really long time. It holds its value.
It's sustained. But more importantly, it
held its value during crisis. A good
collectible will hold its value when ev
when you're panicking, when when
catastrophe hits. And the key thing is
you can't since you can't value Bitcoin,
you can't invest in Bitcoin. You can
trade it. And the we'll talk about
whether you should trade Bitcoin or not.
But often I hear people asking the
question is Bitcoin under or overvalued?
The answer is it cannot be valued. It
can only be priced.
So with that lead in let's take a look
at Bitcoin as currency.
Bitcoin as I said came out in November
of 2008. We're 18 years into the
experiment approximately.
And if you look at Bitcoin's usage as a
currency, it's been extremely
disappointing. There are pockets where
it's gained acceptance. There's an
entire country, El Salvador, where
Bitcoin presumably is the local
currency. I'm not sure that's true
actually, even within El Salvador, but
much of the rest of the world, Bitcoin
is not used in transactions to buy
things. And I regularly give talks at
groups of people who are Bitcoin
advocates. And one of the questions I
ask these groups is when how many of you
have actually used Bitcoin to buy things
out there, a house, a car, your lunch.
Most of them have invested invested or
traded Bitcoin. They bought and sold
Bitcoin, but they haven't used it as a
currency. Now, you can blame
institutional barriers. You know, I'm in
a country where I'm not allowed to use
Bitcoin. India for a long time, you
could use bit there and the barriers can
be legal or regulatory. You can argue
it's a young currency. I'm trying to use
Bitcoin. The other person might not have
heard of it. But you should expect to
see both of those things fading over
time because in more and more countries,
people are allowed to use Bitcoin and
it's no longer a currency that nobody's
heard of, but usage is not picking up,
which raises an interesting question.
Will that change? No, because what I
think part of the reason Bitcoin has
been slow to take off as a currency is
not a very good currency. I know that
sounds like a harsh thing to say, but
it's a very inefficient currency.
Remember that crowd checking you had to
do to make sure that you had the Bitcoin
in your pocket? You go in and pay for
something.
To check it, you got to run through this
algorithm where hundreds of people get
on see if you have it's that's no way to
design a currency. And if you don't
trust anyone, you create more
inefficient currencies. And Bitcoin, one
of the reasons it it's a for its appeal
is it comes with a finite number, 21
million. You hit that, there are going
to be no more Bitcoin out there. No good
currency in history has ever had a
complete cap.
Even during the gold standard, they were
capped at a point in time, but it would
grow. Your economy grew. The amount of
the the currency you had could also
grow. It's not a healthy currency with a
finite limit. So I know there are people
who are upbeat about Bitcoin who still
believe it can become the currency of
the future. I don't think so. Now it can
either become a a niche currency used by
failed countries where the local
currency has failed or it can be a
currency for use in illegal
transactions, the Silk Road, but it's
never going to be a widely used currency
because of the way it's designed. So
that's the currency part. But there's
another argument you can make for
Bitcoin which is as a collectible.
I've often again described Bitcoin as
millennial gold that it you know for
some people it has a characteristics of
gold. So let's pass it through the
collectible test. If you remember the
three questions you ask is it scarce? Is
it durable? Is it desirable? Is it
scarce? Yeah, by definition it is scarce
because of the 21 million bitcoin and no
more. But scarcity alone is the weakest
of all requirements. Right? There are
lots of things that are scarce that
don't have value. And it's scarce only
if you define Bitcoin as an investment
class by itself. If you define
cryptocurrency is your investment class
and Bitcoin as the most common
cryptocurrency today. What if you had
the equivalent of alchemy happen in
Bitcoin? If you remember, alchemy has
been the dream with gold that you can
take common metals and convert them to
gold. Thank god alchemy never worked
because if it did it would have
destroyed gold's value as a collectible
because the scarcity would have imploded
with Bitcoin. Alche with gold alchemy
did not work. Bitcoin, who knows,
alchemy might work. You can create
something that resembles Bitcoin and
gives people who buy Bitcoin an
alternate instrument. It doesn't exist
today, but what if it did? So, it's
scarce, but only if you define Bitcoin
as an investment class by itself. Is it
desirable so far? Yes. I mean, Bitcoin
is its ups and downs, but there are
people out there who desire it. The
question is why? If the only reason they
desire it is because they made money in
it in the past, that's not going to last
because you you have an extended period,
it's down, it's no longer desirable.
There are components of Bitcoin that I
may I think make it appealing to a
subset of people. Remember, we talked
about not trusting governments, not
trusting central banks, the paranoid.
There's a subset of people and I'm not,
you know, putting any any bad labels on
this who've lost trust. They've lost
trust in institutions, the people around
them, governments, and banks. And for
them, Bitcoin is not just a currency.
It's not even it's not even a it's
something that that essentially is the
only thing they have trust in in a world
without trust. So, we'll have to wait
and see. It's been only two decades
since Bitcoin has come out. It's been
desirable so far, but if you put your
pension money into Bitcoin and you're 35
years old, you need it to be desirable
30 years from now. And that's still up
in the air. But there's a bigger issue
with Bitcoin as a collectible that I
want to point to. by using a correlation
matrix a computer at the end of 2020.
2020 if you remember was a was a was a
year of catastrophic events with COVID
and the and the and COVID was not just
stuff for the the economy shutting down
but on markets. I computed the
correlation of different asset classes
that year. Remember, when you want to
when you have a collectible, you want it
to be lightly correlated with everything
else in your portfolio, especially
stocks and bonds and corporates.
Gold fulfills that, right? It's lightly
correlated. Bitcoin though is much more
highly correlated with equities than any
good collectible should be. In fact,
over its lifetime, Bitcoin has behaved
more like risky stock than like gold.
Now, that could pass. Maybe it'll
change. And I keep watching crisis to
see if it'll change because until it
changes go Bitcoin is failing a very
significant collectible test which is
it's not holding its value during crisis
in the first quarter of 2020.
The S&P 500 is down almost a third 33%.
Terrible quarter. One of the worst
quarters we've had the index.
Gold was up about 7%. It held its value.
Bitcoin was down 55%.
In the next 6 months, stocks came
roaring back up about 50%, Bitcoin was
up 85%.
You see where I'm going with this,
right? You cannot have a collectible
that behaves like risky stock.
So, at the moment, if you ask me, would
I pay 80,000 or 90,000 for Bitcoin? I'm
going to say no. But it's a personal
judgment because I don't think it meets
my requirements for a good currency or a
good collectible. Now your view might be
entirely different and that's going to
animate how you think about Bitcoin.
Incidentally, I've spent all of the
session talking about Bitcoin. You're
saying what about the other cryptos?
Let's be be quite honest. Bitcoin sucks
the oxygen out of the air. But there are
other cryptos and they range a spectrum.
There are crypto assets. There are some
cryp tokens you can create that give you
a claim on cash flows. Now those are
assets. You can value them as assets.
You can have crypto commodities know
where they're used as raw material in
something where you might be able to
make money on being used as raw
material. The example I gave is
blockchain and how maybe Ether or
Ethereum is a better lubricant for
blockchains. And if you can figure out a
way to
get charged for that usage, maybe you
can be priced as a commodity. So you
have crypto tokens, crypto commodities,
crypto collectibles, cryptocurrencies.
No one sizefits all. So what I've said
about Bitcoin might not apply to other
cryptos, but pass them through the test.
What is it? Can it be valued before you
take that next step? One final point,
Bitcoin itself is not an asset, but you
can have companies created around
businesses
that are built on Bitcoin that can be
valued as assets. Coinbase is a company
primarily built around Bitcoin, right?
But to the extent that it's a
transactionbased company and you collect
revenues from those transactions, it's a
business. You can value it like a
brokerage house.
So just because you have a business
built around Bitcoin doesn't mean that
you can't value the business. You can
still value the business. Bitcoin itself
is not an asset.
So does Bitcoin belong in your
portfolio? Well, there are two ways you
can use it. One is as an add-on just
like gold. You add it to a portfolio.
But for it to do its job there, it has
to change fundamentally in the way it
behaves because those add-ons are
designed as insurance. The reason we add
gold is as a as a hedge against
catastrophe and and hyperinflation.
Bitcoin so far at least has not
delivered on those. Maybe that'll
change. And if it does, you should add
it on. Or you could trade Bitcoin. Wild
swings in price, right? If you can time
the downs and the ups in Bitcoin, you
never have to invest in anything else.
It's all mood and momentum. But maybe
you can deise a way to call Bitcoin
direction. doesn't work for me, but it
might work for you. So, as you look at
investments in the crypto space, make
your best judgment. Start with that
question of what am I buying? Is it an
asset? Is it a currency? Is it a
collectible? Is it a commodity? Be
honest with yourself. There are many of
these things where you cannot invest in
that crypto. You can only trade it. And
if you're a good trader, all the more
power to you. I hope you found this
session useful. And I thank you very
much for listening.